este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surf sharp luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
türkmenistán es un país si no nos lo
hemos inventado posiblemente no hayas
oído su nombre en tu vida pero créeme
existe y debería preocuparte más de lo
que crees os acordáis de ralph con el de
los simpson puesto urbanista es algo así
como el ranking de los países
[Música]
de hecho voy a hacer un display mer
absolutamente todo lo que vais a ver en
este vídeo es real no nos hemos
inventado nada ni siquiera hemos
intentado exagerar es 100% real veréis
de entrada a este país es el escenario
de la catástrofe ecológica más estúpida
de la historia y si habéis oído bien
estúpida básicamente en el año 1971 el
estado türkmenistán o que era satélite
de la unión soviética mandó a unos
geólogos a buscar gas natural en el
desierto y no se les ocurrió nada mejor
que construir una plataforma de
extracción justo encima de una cueva
subterránea que podía salir mal pues
efectivamente la plataforma se hundió
dejando un cráter del tamaño de un campo
de fútbol un cráter de donde salía us
metano a cascoporro y que creéis que se
les ocurrió para evitar el escape de gas
haber pensado bien si vosotros sois
encontraréis un cráter gigantesco que
escupe gas natural que es lo que nunca
jamás de los jamases haríais pues
exactamente eso es lo que hicieron a
alguien se le ocurrió la brillante idea
de decir
y si lo vendemos fuego desde entonces la
llamada puerta del infierno sigue en
llamas y no parece que vaya a apagarse
pronto
y diréis y ahora qué hacen con esta
puerta del infierno es una atracción
turística es una zona restringida para
el público para evitar accidentes pues
nada de eso la puerta del infierno se
usa para esto
si ese señor que veis conduciendo como
si fuera el mismísimo fernando alonso es
nada más y nada menos que el dictador de
türkmenistán un hombre que se llama
gurbanguly berdimuhamedov y si ya lo sé
el nombre es un trabalenguas y si lo de
conducir un radio alrededor de la puerta
del infierno es su forma de hacer
propaganda política os lo digo en serio
la dictadura de türkmenistán es única en
la historia y diréis ballet bien un
dictador que está como una regadera y
que sólo por eso ya nos tendría que
importar türkmenistán pues lo cierto es
que hay mucho más pensadlo bien la
existencia de esta puerta del infierno
demuestra una cosa este país tiene gas
natural y no hablamos de unas reservas
normales
atentos türkmenistán tiene las cuartas
reservas de gas natural más grandes del
mundo para que os hagáis una idea rusia
y qatar son los dos países que más gas
exportan del mundo
[Música]
la fifa elige a rusia y qatar para
organizar los mundiales de 2018 y 2022
como veis tener gas significa tener
amigos en todo el mundo y fijaos rusia
tiene reservas de gas para 58 años y
qatar las tiene para los próximos 141
años
bueno pues türkmenistán tiene gas para
los próximos atentos 317 años si a eso
le sumamos que solo tienen 6 millones de
habitantes parece razonable pensar que
los turcomanos tiene que estar nadando
en la abundancia verdad pues nada de eso
así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es por qué türkmenistán apenas explota
su gas natural qué diantres pasa en este
país y otra pregunta se podría ver este
vídeo desde türkmenistán pues a esta os
puede responder ya mismo no la respuesta
es no al igual que china o irán
türkmenistán tiene bloqueado el acceso a
youtube ya sabéis que internet tampoco
se libra de la censura y tampoco se
libra del crimen seguro que alguno de
vosotros habrá intentado alguna vez
conectarse a su banco desde la wifi de
una cafetería
pues por favor no lo volváis a hacer
cuando utilizáis una wifi pública para
algo tan importante y tan privado como
vuestro banco estáis abriéndole la
puerta a todos los hackers que hay por
ahí siempre hemos oído hablar en las
noticias de filtraciones de datos
hackeos y creedme esas cosas también os
pueden ocurrir a vosotros y como podéis
evitar todo este tipo de problemas pues
muy sencillo
usando una vpn para conectarnos a
internet una vpn como subsal
[Música]
si utilizáis su shark no solamente
podréis ver este vídeo desde cualquier
parte del mundo incluido türkmenistán
sino que además lo podréis hacer de
forma segura y no sólo hablamos de
hackers psuv shark es una vpn fantástica
por muchas otras razones seguro que
todos sabéis que ha ido alguna vez en
una de estas webs de spam intentan
estafarnos con popups a este tipo de
prácticas se las llama phishing pues
bien su usar tiene una herramienta que
se llama clean web que bloquea todos
estos popups y todos esos enlaces que
pueden resultar un auténtico peligro
pero no sólo eso veréis con una única
cuenta de su usar podéis registrar todos
los dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tablet el portátil o en el ordenador de
sobremesa no hay ningún límite de
dispositivos y como siempre tenemos una
oferta muy especial para todos vosotros
que seguís visual múnich y básicamente
si utilizáis el código político termina
banca tendréis un 83 por ciento de
descuento más un mes extra totalmente
gratis es más podéis probar su usar
durante los primeros 30 días sin ningún
compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los
y dicho todo esto ahora sí vamos a ver
un poco de historia
los tentadores más locos de la historia
vale ya lo hemos dicho türkmenistán es
una dictadura pero hay algo peor a que
tu propio país sea una dictadura pues y
que tu presidente se crea el mismísimo
quini west y tortura con su flow a todos
los turcomanos atentos
[Música]
en una es decir que no es que no haya
libertad de expresión no es que los
ciudadanos estén obligados a alabar a su
líder supremo es que también tienen que
bailar con su música me pregunto cómo
serán los youtubers de türkmenistán
hola mis queridos amigos turcomanos hoy
en analizando la maravillosa música de
nuestro querido y amado líder supremo
tenemos esta maravillosa pieza titulada
oda a los caballos miren qué carisma
tiene nuestro adorado líder
[Música]
porque virtuosismo en los teclados por
favor ya puedo volver a casa con mi
familia que tengo hambre y ya no tengo
familia mi casa malditos hijos de erc
quiero quiero decir gracias amado líder
por ayudarme a ahorrar en mis regalos de
navidad a estas alturas seguro que os
estaréis preguntando cómo es posible que
no hayáis oído hablar antes de
türkmenistán tan pocos extrañéis veréis
si el mundo fuera un hotel
türkmenistán colgó hace tiempo el cartel
de no molestar la dictadura turcomana no
quiere que se sepa nada de lo que pasa
en su país así ha sido desde su
independencia de la unión soviética en
el año 1991 de hecho a duras penas se
sabe cuántas plataformas de gas hay en
el país o si realmente funcionan nadie
sabe si el país tiene carreteras o no
prácticamente todo lo que nos llega de
este país es la música de su presidente
de verdad merece la pena que la busques
en youtube pero si os parece que el
presidente berdimuhamedov es un
personaje de cuidado es porque aún no
hemos hablado de su predecesor
saparmurat niyázov o como él quise que
le llamaran turkmenbashí que significa
en la lengua local el líder de todos los
tucumanos
i
veréis niyázov era secretario general
del partido comunista de türkmenistán en
tiempos de la unión soviética desde 1985
hasta su muerte en 2006 fue el máximo
dirigente de turno lista entrar la
desintegración de la unión soviética en
1991 ocupó la presidencia del país lejos
de evolucionar hacia una democracia
niyázov se proclamó presidente vitalicio
y türkmenistán se consolidó en una
dictadura totalmente aislada del mundo
un régimen autoritario sin absolutamente
ningún respeto a los derechos humanos
vamos es quienes hablas de derechos
humanos por ahí y se ríen en tu cara
pero es que aquí no termina la historia
veréis niyázov impuso un culto a su
personalidad que era como decirlo un
poco extravagante
a su mayor afición era construirse
estatuas de oro enormes por todo
türkmenistán pero en lo que a política
exterior se refiere niyázov fue bastante
más discreto proclamó la neutralidad
eterna de türkmenistán es decir que este
hombre el tal niyázov o formen basic
como le queráis llamar pensó y dejó en
paz a los demás
nadie se meterá conmigo y hay que
reconocerlo fue una decisión fantástica
porque de momento a estos dictadores
nadie les ha dicho absolutamente nada
también les ha ido que en su momento
niyázov ordenó elegir en la capital en
las cavas un gigantesco monumento a la
neutralidad y en lo alto como no podría
ser de otra manera colocaron una estatua
dorada de 12 metros de turkmenbashí y
ojo no es una estatua dorada cualquiera
es una estatua que tiene un motor para
estar girando siempre cara al sol por
cierto se dedicará al sol a los
dictadores no sé por qué les debe
fascinar pero esperad porque todavía no
habéis visto nada si alguno pensaba que
mi gato era un tipo superficial
obsesionado con el oro y el lujo os
equivocáis él era un dictador comunista
y tenía sus inquietudes intelectuales
así que había veces que se ponía
profundo y entonces le daba por la
puerta
tan fuerte le daba que escribió un libro
de poemas el ruin ama traducido como el
libro del alma hasta aquí todo normal
vale unos escribe en el libro rojo otros
el manual de resistencia pues vale
villazón el libro del alma bien el
problema es que todo turcomano tenía que
aprender se lo desde el principio hasta
el final en el sistema educativo era
imprescindible y para la vida diaria
también por ejemplo si te quería sacar
el carnet de conducir en türkmenistán de
repente te llegaba el examinador y te
decía sección cuarta página 155 y ya
podías conducir mejor que fernando
alonso que yo respondía lávate adelantan
hagan o suspenso inmediato y atentos
porque si todo esto os parece poco el
señor villazón todavía quiso torturar
aún más a sus ciudadanos con éstos
sí türkmenistán es el lugar por
excelencia de los monumentos imposibles
e improbables el propio turkmenbashí o
niyázov ordenó levantar esta estatua a
su libro un gigantesco ejemplar que
todas las tardes se abre y se cierra
pero que todavía no hemos terminado
porque también cambió el nombre de los
días y los meses de hecho enero se
llamaba turkmenbashí en su honor abril
se llamaba como su madre urban zoltan y
por supuesto septiembre como su libro el
ruin ama
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando un
dictador así que haría que el mismísimo
kim jong-un parezca josé mujica
seguramente dejaría la presidencia en
herencia a su hijo murat verdad pues no
fijaos como debía de ser de crápula el
tal murat que turkmenbashí y prefirió
como sucesor a su dentista antes que su
propio hijo porque si mis queridos
amigos de visual política el presidente
berdimuhamedov lo que fue toda la vida
es dentista y ahora es peor que un dolor
de muelas para todos los turcomanos
[Música]
su comienzo en principio daba ciertas
esperanzas sobre el país de repente
türkmenistán volvió al calendario normal
y dejó de ser obligatorio en
conocimiento del ruin ama e incluso
retiró algunas de las estatuas de oro de
niyázov es más término hubo algún que
otro avance en la economía al igual que
su vecino uzbekistán del que ya hemos
hablado en visual polític durante
décadas lo único aprovechable de
türkmenistán era el algodón el resto era
economía de subsistencia sí es cierto
los soviéticos buscaron con insistencia
gas natural y desde luego que lo
encontraron pero era muy difícil de
extraer sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta
que cuando construyeron las plantas de
extracción abrieron un cráter sin
embargo en el año 2006 türkmenistán
halló lo que podríamos llamar el
yacimiento de su vida
[Música]
y claros podéis pensar bien pues las
cosas empezarían a funcionar en este
país se muere el dictador turkmenbashí
el nuevo presidente parece medio normal
y encima descubren un enorme yacimiento
de gas natural que podría salir mal pues
atentos
el dictador de türkmenistán acaba de
erigir una enorme estatua dorada de sí
mismo montando a caballo de verdad no me
preguntéis que comen en türkmenistán o
que pasa en el palacio presidencial de
ese país para que al final termines
convertido en una especie de rey midas y
goldfinger pero perversión estúpida lo
de estos tíos no es normal es verdad que
berdimuhamedov no ha llegado todavía al
nivel de turba en base pero poco le
falta y también se ha puesto un
sobrenombre berdimuhamedov es arcada qué
quiere decir el protector y os estaréis
preguntando y que ha hecho arcada con el
gas natural pues atentos
y el combustible del dragón brace
türkmenistán es un desierto de hecho es
el décimo desierto más grande del mundo
el desierto de karakum ocupa el 60% de
su territorio y quedaos con este nombre
karakum porque hay algo peor que la
mayor parte de tu país es un desierto
pues sí que tu presidente le dedique una
canción y que encima tengas que aplaudir
y bailar como si no existiera mañana
yo no sé vosotros pero yo el de verde le
hacía ministro lo bueno es que si en
türkmenistán hay algo aparte del
desierto de karakum es el gas natural y
la mitad del gas natural que produce
actualmente türkmenistán es para consumo
propio la otra mitad es lógico la
exportan y hay dos formas de exportar el
gas natural si seguir visual es político
desde hace tiempo ya lo sabéis dos
tercios del comercio mundial de gas se
realiza mediante gasoductos pero el
tercio restante se hace por barco
gracias al gas natural licuado son los
llamados metaneros que transportan el
gas en estado líquido a muy baja
temperatura el 75 por ciento del mercado
mundial del gn l se mueve por el
pacífico y tiene como principales
destinos japón china corea del sur y la
india y aquí es donde comienzan los
problemas para türkmenistán el principal
es que no tienen salida al océano es
decir que licuar el gas no es una opción
por tanto sólo les queda una opción la
de los gasoductos y claro que hace falta
para hacer gasoductos inversión y como
os podéis imaginar quién va a invertir
dinero en türkmenistán donde la élite
política tiene manga ancha hay
corrupción no hay ningún tipo de
transparencia ni seguridad jurídica
vamos que a ver quién es el guapo que se
va ahí a hacer negocios con este
panorama quién ha mostrado más interés
por el gas turcomano pues en un
principio china que como también es una
dictadura sabe cómo lidiar con este tipo
de países y tanto que sabe el dragón
rojo apareció por türkmenistán en el
momento en el que se produjo el hallazgo
del gran yacimiento de gas su carta de
presentación fue una lluvia de millones
que se convirtió en dinero fresco para
los caprichos de arcada a cambio de la
explotación del yacimiento y la
construcción del gasoducto de 1800
kilómetros que conecta türkmenistán con
la frontera china
cuando ese gasoducto comenzó a operar
aportaba más de un tercio del gas que
consumía china lo que ocurre es que
desde entonces la demanda china se
multiplicó por tres y eso nos lleva a
que actualmente el gas turcomano
representa un 12 por ciento del gas que
requiere el 'gigante asiático' de todos
modos türkmenistán sigue siendo el
principal país al que china le compra el
gas natural el problema es que como os
podéis imaginar todo el gas que se está
llamando china no está aportando gran
cosa a las cuentas truco humanas todos
los analistas coinciden en que el gas
está sirviendo como pago en especie por
todos los préstamos que en su día
recibió la dictadura de arcada y luego
hay otro problema es que el dinero que
llega el dictador se lo gasta a manos
llenas su apuesta por diversificar la
economía e impulsar el turismo ha tenido
dos grandes hitos el primero fue
construir el mayor aeropuerto de asia
central se ha gastado 2.400 millones de
euros en un aeropuerto con capacidad
para 17 millones de viajeros para que os
hagáis una idea es un volumen de
viajeros similar al del aeropuerto de
jerusalén
y el otro es de esta forma la
registración difícil y estable
gasteiz
pues si el señor berdimuhamedov pensó un
día si tengo desierto y quiero turistas
que puedo hacer pues la versión
soviética de las vegas' oye a quien no
le gustaría ver eso de la puerta del
infierno o las estatuas de oro el
monumento gigantesco un libro es más a
mí me dan entradas para ver un concierto
de este señor y yo voy cuál es el
problema pues que a nuestro querido
dictador turcomano se le olvidó un
pequeño detalle y es que para atraer
turistas hay que permitir que entren en
el país
spears hay que facilitar visados
pasaportes y eso es algo que no le
termina de hacer gracia cuál es el
resultado pues que todos esos siete
lazos están vacíos la mayor ocupación
que alcanzan es del 30 por ciento así
que su proyecto turístico pues os podéis
imaginar dónde están pero atentos porque
no hemos terminado su última apuesta es
la organización de eventos deportivos si
han gastado 5.000 millones de dólares en
un macro recinto para albergar el
archiconocido y ximo torneo asiático de
artes marciales pero atentos porque la
dictadura ya está moviendo hilos para
próximos acontecimientos
las gamas organizará el mundial de
ciclismo en pista en 2021 de hecho
tenemos imágenes de cómo convenció al
a la unión ciclista internacional
con motores de entre medias feitor
kirchner pierdo ganaron no sanará
también me pasa de sol por doctor de
melón guiara roo wistron vivenciar cada
base chapman satán no saben adaptar a
coca te vienes gourmet persona no
sean las de un formó cuál es más
berdimuhamedov está para ir a los juegos
olímpicos
en resumen que en türkmenistán hay
muchísimo gas una parte se lo está
llevando china precio de saldo y el
dinero que ingresa a cada se lo gasta en
estupideces bueno atentos que tampoco
creáis que se lo gastan todo
[Música]
economist informa de que 23 mil millones
de dólares procedentes de türkmenistán
se han acumulado en cuentas de alemania
el único motivo de optimismo para los
turcomanos es la llamada transición
energética lo que dura la dictadura es
imposible de saber pero todo indica que
el mundo querrá más gas natural a medio
plazo sin ir más lejos
europa estaría encantada de recibir más
gas natural con tal de reducir su
dependencia del gas ruso no le
importaría hacer pactos con una
dictadura por rara y excéntrica que sea
ya lo vimos en el vídeo que hicimos
sobre azerbaiyán cuyo enlace os dejo a
la descripción el mayor problema para
türkmenistán es nuevamente su situación
porque veréis construir un gasoducto
bajo el mar caspio es la opción más
directa para llegar a europa pero en
primer lugar
azerbaiyán quiere usar los gasoductos de
europa para vender su gas no el
turcomano
[Música]
y rusia y gran no pondrán facilidades a
que se construya este gasoducto por el
caspio en otras palabras que podría o
bien ir por irán que con el tema de las
sanciones estadounidenses no es una
opción o ir por rusia en cuyo caso
europa no solucionaría su problema de
dependencia del kremlin es decir que con
este panorama al margen de los chinos el
único negocio que parece viable es el
gasoducto tapi y diréis qué es eso del
tapiz pues muy sencillo türkmenistán
afganistán pakistán inter
diez mil millones de dólares invertidos
para exportar una cantidad similar a la
que türkmenistán vende actualmente a
china el 42% del gas será para
afganistán otro 42% para la india y
afganistán se quedaría con el 16%
restante en principio la idea parece
buena así que veremos si realmente les
funciona lo cierto es que este gasoducto
supondría una auténtica inyección a la
economía turcomana la cosa es si ese
dinero llega de verdad al pueblo o si
gurbanguly berdimuhamedov se lo sigue
gastando en estupideces así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
türkmenistán aprovechará el tren de la
transición energética o la dictadura
seguirá derrochando dinero a cascoporro
si os ocurre alguna idea mejor en la que
gastaron el dinero del gas es más cuál
es vuestra canción favorita de arcada el
rap de türkmenistán o la del desierto de
karakum podéis decirme lo que pensáis en
los comentarios mientras tanto no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto